[Music]
what rights do people have and where do
they come from who gets to make
decisions for others and on what
authority and how can we organize
society to meet people's needs
these questions challenged an entire
nation during the upheaval of the French
Revolution by the end of the 18th
century Europe had undergone a profound
intellectual and cultural shift known as
the Enlightenment philosophers and
artists promoted reason and human
freedom over tradition and religion the
rise of a middle class and printed
materials encouraged political awareness
and the American Revolution had turned a
former English colony into an
independent republic yet France one of
the largest and richest countries in
Europe was still governed by an ancient
regime of three rigid social classes
called estates the monarch king louis
xvi based his authority on divine right
and granted special privileges to the
first and second estates the catholic
clergy and the nobles the Third Estate
middle-class merchants and craftsmen as
well as over 20 million peasants had far
less power and they were the only ones
who paid taxes not just to the king but
to the other estates as well in bad
harvest years taxation could leave
peasants with almost nothing while the
King and Nobles lived lavishly on their
extracted wealth but as France sank into
debt due to its support of the American
Revolution and its long-running war with
England change was needed King Louie
appointed finance ministers Jacques
Necker who pushed for tax reforms and
won public support by openly publishing
the government's finances but the King's
advisors strongly opposed these
initiatives desperate for a solution the
King called a meeting of the Estates
General an assembly of representatives
from the three estates for the first
time in a hundred and seventy-five years
although the Third Estate represented 98
percent of the French population its
vote was equal to each of the other
estates and unsurprisingly both of the
upper classes favored keeping their
privileges realizing they couldn't get
fair representation the Third Estate
broke off declared themselves the
National Assembly and pledged to draft a
new constitution with or without the
other estates King Louie ordered the
first and second estates to meet with
the National Assembly but he also
dismissed Necker his popular finance
minister in response thousands of
outraged Parisians joined with
sympathetic soldiers to storm the
Bastille prison a symbol of royal power
and a large storehouse of weapons the
revolution had begun as rebellions
spread throughout the country the feudal
system was abolished the Assembly's
Declaration of the Rights of Man and
citizen proclaimed a radical idea for
the time that individual rights and
freedoms were fundamental to human
nature and government existed only to
protect them their privileges gone many
Nobles fled abroad begging foreign
rulers to invade France and restore
order and while Louie remained as the
figurehead of the constitutional
monarchy he feared for his future in
1791 he tried to flee the country but
was caught the attempted escape
shattered people's faith in the king
the royal family was arrested and the
King charged with treason after a trial
the once revered King was publicly
beheaded signaling the end of 1000 years
of monarchy and finalizing the September
21st declaration of the first French
Republic governed by the motto
liberté égalité a fraternity nine months
later Queen marie-antoinette
a foreigner long mocked as madam deficit
for her extravagant reputation was
executed as well but the revolution
would not end there some leaders not
content with just changing the
government sought to completely
transform French society its religion
its street names even its calendar as
multiple factions formed the extremists
jacobins led by maximilien robespierre
launched a reign of terror to suppress
the slightest dissent executing over
20,000 people before the Jacobins own
downfall meanwhile france found itself
at war with neighboring monarchs seeking
to strangle the revolution before it
spread amidst the chaos a general named
Napoleon Bonaparte took charge becoming
Emperor as he claimed to defend the
revolutions democratic values all in all
the revolution saw three constitutions
and five governments within ten years
followed by decades alternating between
monarchy and revolt before the next
republic formed in 1871 and while we
celebrate the French Revolutions ideals
we still struggle with many of the same
basic questions raised over two
centuries ago
[Music]